citizens of the reject Nation Greg here
today so finish assembling uh the final
part of our reaction to the cut scenes
for Spider-Man 2 and realized did not
have a YouTube intro did not shoot one
so I'm shooting one right now and I
wanted to take this opportunity to say
thank you to all who have been watching
all five of these parts part five is
indeed my favorite of the five-part
reaction uh for this video game I want
to say thank you especially to all who
have been understanding of the fact that
yeah did not have time and I probably
won't to really complete the game for I
don't know qu quite a while honestly and
uh anyone I thought about it too and
just a little side note we've done video
game reviews before Spider-Man Miles
Morales being one of them after playing
the game and beating it most of the time
like like 99% of the time we just talk
about the characters and the story and
we don't really touch on the game play
and because that's just naturally where
I'm drawn to mostly talking about
regardless to me this was actually like
like a fitting experience and allows me
to avoid spoilers for the next couple
months as I take my time with actually
playing the game because usually gaming
is not something that uh we we review so
this was like a fun little addition to
bring onto the channel and and like when
I say I don't have time that's mainly
because of the fact that the editing for
all the other stuff generally takes an
obnoxious amount of time we mainly do
the movie and TV show reactions and you
guys can figure out the rest of the math
but the the general math for things like
if you look at the runtime of started
figuring out from like 40 to 45 minutes
for something of a runtime generally
takes me for just the just the editing
I'm not talking about like the
thumbnails or anything like that takes
about four uh two and a half to four and
a half hours for every thing that's like
a 45 minute runtime so you can do the
mouth on something that's like shorter
or longer and you see that that is
primarily what we do here so it's like a
fun little addition granted this has
been um far less time to assemble like
it only takes me about three and and a
half hours per part to put together so
that is less timec consuming than the
other ones yeah maybe down the road uh
when I really figur it out or really am
able to better manage the schedule in
time uh for something in the future to
actually sit down and maybe do a live
stream or recording of it I'll let you
guys know but in the meantime really
enjoy doing this and uh hopefully you
guys enjoy part five and thank you to
Andrew as well for joining me on the
journey would not have wanted to cover
with anyone else all righty guys thank
you reject Nation F that like
button once I let my mom know this she
still has a
son I know oh my God I think I know
what's going to happen I think Harry's
going to get it and then Harry will be
the one who kills Craven as Venom and
then Craven's going to get what he
wanted watch my prediction come
true sounds hello MJ sounds legit I got
the suit off and I'm so sorry for go on
for treating you and everyone I care
about like absolute crap I'm heading to
OC Corp to store the suit until Dr Conor
and I can figure out what to do does
Harry know no no Harry's just going to
be resentful it's a relief to hear you
sounding like yourself
again go wrap things up there's not some
world where you can temporarily give it
back to Harry but then how do you get it
off I mean I guess you could do loud
noise if there's a spot where you can
like keep him contained with it just
keep him
alive you know what I mean yeah until
you have that other cure with Norman
yeah if there's a way where you can
isolate him somewhere like you did the
first time
yeah God speed
Spider-Man don't tell Harry
uhoh you finally got it off
my hero look okay he's developing the
green C
Harry we've got to destroy
it it's too dangerous I don't want you
to lose
yourself like I
did Pete I'm going to lose my life I
don't understand Connor said it was I
saved your life you won't save
mine do you want me to die oh
god oh
no ah there it
is
uh-oh sorry I rejected you let me come
back
[__] Andrew what' I tell you man I said
you were probably going to be right I
tell you man I did not say you were
going to be wrong oh my God we are
Venom Harry are you vom oh
God yes oh
damn
hurry
[Music]
oh no don't hurt him uh I think you have
to worry about Venom
Hur oh my God he's
humongous oh and now yeah at that stage
now we're symbiot is mad at Peter for
rejecting him oh yeah for
sure awesome
um stop
nonlethal just get it off of
him
fantastic wow oh my god oh you get to
play as Venom oh oh [__] wow I was not
expecting
that h
wow oh I can't wait for
[Applause]
that yeah the told you the Venom's going
to kill Craven th% he's going to get
what he
[Music]
wanted New York has taking quite a
beating in this game oh I just love like
how wet everything is Icky it's slimy
the elements of it all hell yeah at last
so he finally get me my match you didn't
want to fight
Spider-Man know know he knows that
Craven knows he's not going to hold back
yeah
exactly kill him he's going to do it
he's going to do it
oh did not think we go that far with the
violence oh regener regeneration yeah
still
gross nice prediction yeah I've been
predicting I've been getting my
predictions
down did you read the spoilers before we
started of course
not
oh my
God just got to follow a narrative
[Applause]
Andrew smile thank you there it
is oh my God how is going to kill
[Music]
him oh I wanted to see his whole head
come off awesome I mean the game's not
rated M for Mature so I don't think they
could show that
awesome
damn he's going to be okay though right
yeah I mean Harry's got to possess that
memory
[Music]
now
cool that was
great wow you still get to stay with
that this is I know really interesting
so many perspectives you hop between
here it's like you're on the Journey of
with darkness in this one as
mama
Mom I
don't what did I just do also seems like
don't be scared honey you finally have
the power to do what we've always
wanted we're going to heal the world
Tony Todd messing with the Consciousness
out let me show you
that's
crazy you know we were talking about how
it didn't corrupt him earlier seems like
how on his grief yeah well that too like
how you're feeling in the like yeah how
you're feeling because he was in a happy
state of mind
so happy to be alive happy with his
friends didn't feel any betray oh my
God love the expressiveness of
this how was the city not toally
destroyed at this point
property my
god there malevolent Vines spreading
everywhere we are New
York whoa blackout we're going to heal
everyone he's got the he's just got the
most menacing voice
[Music]
ever it's a
virus that design is
[Applause]
incredible
consequences it's okay Peter you didn't
miss much
I would say this could drive Norman to
be the green copin after this what did
you
do oh my
God how am I going to find you out there
it's pretty easy look for the big big
menacing violent monster with the crazy
Vines protruding everywhere our EMF
badges were RF
enabled using that Peter
brain
are those like oh cuz it's it's
spreading throughout New York yeah miles
I need help with these things got your
messages sorry I've been looking for my
mom assume you saw Craven
dead
what
no
how his head was bitten off you think it
was Harry maybe probably maybe probably
who else could have done it Craven's
like a very formidable foe certain
sounds made you weak I know he just
doesn't want to believe it but we can't
just carry it around no but I have this
mixing app on my phone I can recreate
the B Sonic elements then we can use it
against Harry in his army oh clever
Venom Army huh you see how that uh train
was driving by I actually got rammed by
one I was swinging by earlier funny we
did
it let's get to your mom and get Sonica
burst
Integrity she with her
boyfriend Spider-Man oh no she's with
geny that's her boyfriend what happened
I took your advice I let go of some
things that didn't serve
me come on
okay that really sucks I thought I was
going to die my life was flashing from
my eyes you're good
man that time when we went mini golfing
for my birthday and I got that hole in
one to win I cheated I picked up the
ball and dropped it in when you weren't
looking and I you were eight this game
is all about betrayal the sandwiches you
traded for at lunch but I went along
with it because I knew how much you
loved my mom's bonan and I'm seeing
someone new by the way her name's Andy
and she's great and please don't kill me
but I just thought of a sequel for
speeden
nagon him oh she's real
cool let's get up town I'll make you
something good for
dinner next step find
Harry oh goodness that statue I got is
anything to go off it's not going to be
such an easy
battle
MJ MJ
where's
yeah
Pete you look
[Music]
tense did she know we need to talk 2000%
no you must get tired making the world a
better place every single
day but I can
help all you have to do is let
me this isn't you
wrong this is the real
me it's okay
Harry I finally have the power to
realize our
vision are
you giving up on
me I really love how again the way they
use that
the scared the crap out of me something
for like a greater good is what they
always believe it
does do not call us a thing we are not
Harry we say it are Tony
Todd
yes he said
it oh
MJ oh damn she took the hit for him
you'll do crazy things when you're in
love
Greg yo what's about to
happen oh my God I thought he was going
to like to really
[Music]
murderer
no
what no
way no
way better
go oh my
God
who oh [__] I was not expecting this oh
[__] show him what he's
missing appeal to her can
have too late scream yep
MJ I'm sorry oh my god did not expect
this to
happen remember your book I'm so glad
voided all spoilers holy [__] D I had no
idea this would
happen said you
scream how conflicting of a situation if
I helped one person it was worth
it oh yeah her book about some
caria
man that is a conflict for
real I mean he normally pulls his
punches but yeah this is extra
conflicting this isn't what you
want how do you defeat something like
this when you need to save them and not
kill them you're Mary je
Watson you want the truth sh this what
that's you
for first little piss you
off I want the
truth there
nope you're a
[Applause]
mistake sh It Off
a are you am
I make love right
here I'm okay this game is so tense tell
you
wait not yet there just so much about
over over coming the darkness within you
Watson where are you with my Apple FRS
I'm starving and I quit kiss my ass yeah
quit
[Applause]
what she should start her own
podcast should be called kiss my ass I
thought I lost you GRE I hope you first
subscrib been L for a while
now not just to the
Symbiote for months I've been
trying to be something I'm
not I'm glad you're
back you're beautiful Mary sorry it
wasn't
you and I wasn't me early I love how
understanding they are to each other
it's so beautiful they utilize the
darkness of the Symbio to enhance the uh
well they're always there kind of hive
mind in there yeah the intimacy of it
all I saw
you and Harry
he's going after
this rock oh the rock that Kurt Connor's
had mhm yeah miles is it City Hall
go I love you I love
you well now that she's not working
there she's definitely going to move
in if he survives dude they're going to
have to sell that house oh yeah that's
true now that he doesn't have that job
bet the Emily May Foundation well
depending on what happens with Harry I
just saw him in Queens he turned MJ into
one of those symbiotes but worse what
she's okay she broke out of it she
looked kind of
hot
[__] all right so at this point you're
obviously clearly done fighting Hunters
cuz Craven obviously is gone
yeah these look like tough
opponents Mr negative he's getting the
Redemption
or
Spiderman I'm done paying for my sins I
shall help Ste some of this thing inside
him oh wow I think I can clear it out of
him but only if I go to the source I'm
going in with you oh no is he going to
die uh I could see
[Music]
that
wow it's it's so mature of miles to let
go of his
hatred find
Spider-Man all of this dark matter
should lead us toward
him what an interesting perspective for
both of them in the negative world like
this just finding their deem I wonder if
we going to see like ant May here or
something makes sense why Spider-Man
that's interesting most of us are here
because of him down here I think I found
something I mean he's he's probably in
so much pain still
oh yeah May was so important to him for
sure
octopus scor we getting our Sinister 6
Electro yeah Sinister 6 where's
Rhino there he
is what was that
as a sinister six man you know exactly
what it
was he's having a deal with all the
Peter's demons yeah your
power does have the same effect in
here
yeah I guess it does yeah we really
should change his name like you said to
Mr
positive if we clear this out we just
might be able to save him
[Music]
this is a really great lesson for mil to
be learning this like it's really the
path of a true
Spider-Man maybe fa
but there such a level of forgiveness
too more option go sacrifice yourself I
transfer all of my power into the
Symbiote I think that could neutralize
it oh wow and free
Peter what will happen to you you'll die
I guess we'll find
out yeah cuz he's had that power since
he was a little kid since Norman and a
experimented on him well 1986 if this is
my last chance to say anything to you
I won't forgive you nor should he he's
just not in
me you can still make the right choice
though but I can't carry this hate for
you anymore
man oh damn so let's set things right
man the dialogue is so freaking good in
this
game
so
touching it's going to be so hard when
they eventually add miles in a live
action film to talk
[Applause]
this
wow
oh maybe Lee was just
freed he's just a
man but the powers would kept him
alive there it is yeah oh with
me this is all my
fault I'm
sorry I'm
sorry
we's been watching one big grief
Journey we did
it come on Spider-Man
Miles
Spider-Man Spider-Man wake
up
yeah oh
[__]
whoa
go I've got this aome
suit what
whoa oh cuz the negative energy I got it
okay took me a second to process that I
thought we lost
you call it the positive energy suit
guess I should thank
you I spent years of my life consumed
Vengeance and lost everything for
it you to reminded me that that's not
who I am that was so great when you help
someone you help everyone you help
everyone than you
may you did say in the last game to me
now it's you who inspires
me to set things
right your
way he's going to give himself up to the
police wow reforming your greatest enemy
can't say I've ever done
that Miles you're a better Spider-Man
was
right why would the city need me when
they have you when it has
you
I don't
know this city still looks like a twool
Spider-Man job to
[Music]
me that suit is so sick just get out of
here Spider-Man over here hey chief
thanks for
coming we've managed to set our
explosives in every Zone except the last
one
the demo crew's in there there's four of
them I'll find them just keep your
radios open and make sure nobody touches
that
Detonator spiderbot can search faster in
there than I can your time to shine
little guy this still part of the story
line
what are they oh I didn't say anything
to the police never never even mentioned
the flame I just I just wanted out then
you should have remembered we all go out
the same way we come
in
painfully yeah yeah dude I love this
antivenom get out of
here Fool's Beacon prophecy that you'd
face us eventually prophecy oh man I've
always wanted to be in one of those not
crazy about the nickname
though you're prolonging the
inevitable so what's my prophecy endless
fighting death by bu forarms get your
timing
downn what the rest of you that's it oh
okay wonder if he just keeps the
antivenom suit forever
now who guys can we take this
outside that reminds me of the first
Teenage M Ninja Turtles film is everyone
okay besides Me Knocking you out
obviously we are better than you ever
will
be H for coming
here who are you people the only ones
worthy enough to survive what's
coming you'd be
dead
flame bur's
Eternal oh that a wraith room The
Wraith
yeah you read lenthal interacting with
his wife so what's your deal
there you are
hey you never did like me smoking spider
cup
Yuri little life's call me wraith fits
pretty well I think plays by her own
rules I tried where have you been all
faith in the justice system takes the
law now into her own hands see hear
Sony's developing a wraith movie now are
they really apparently yeah I could see
that one making over a billion
dollars
easily and they said it couldn't be
done well it's so easy now to make a
billion dollars in film so the wiring
for the cells leads right
here oh working with wraith on
this I mean makes sense they worked
together for so long so before
this we really need to stop being like
this
Yuri people will think you're trying to
kill
me never thought you'd be able to trick
anyone into joining one of your little
clubs
again love is not a trick none of this
is love I extended my hand when nobody
else would
I doubt you this must be some big setup
for part three Beacon there would have
done the
same but what would it take for you to
love
me tell me where you're hiding and I'll
show
you the old hospital North of
Historia stop by
anytime if you're both worthy only Thor
is you play this uh just that part but I
didn't get any further with
wraith shouldn't take us long to get to
the
hospital
Yuri this is the most obvious trap I've
ever
seen and I fought Trapster
we can't wait on this one you don't know
him I wonder if this inclusion in the
game was necessary for this
one if it'll wrap up to the entire rest
of the story what are you
doing
I mean Norman's always been good to him
so I can't imagine he's
going just give me back my son give me
back my son I understood that one too we
are your
son look at us just needs to give him a
ransom we are heal
strong this is what you want Tony Todd's
killing it isn't
it stop Harry we can help
you
ohaz where's the rest of
it
ah oh no
don't
o it's interesting having like Venom
because you feel hairy in there it's and
you're normally just so used to just
you're only with Venom also that you're
with the person underneath it yeah but
also you feel the hatred of the Symbio
toward
fused towards find way to save him you
can't but you can still stop the
Symbiote kill
Harry by killing the
host
please
save my
boy oh yeah we're getting Green Goblin
in the third one for sure they've been
setting that up for a long time
yeah when you went into his uh into his
apartment in the first game you got the
uh you saw the helmet the weapons yeah
yeah and some of the pumpkin I'm saying
this is going to be the the ultimate
ultimate push
yeah are we in the
church
[Music]
New York has never been
worse I mean after the events of the
first game and Miles Morales but I know
that was just Harlem but still
like how much damage can this city
take meanwhile Yuri's dealing with
culus there's got to be some kind of
payoff there like why would he even show
that you
know
amidst all
[Music]
this l Hold the changes to not an alien
is
it it's time for a m moral is original
you
know one of one
it looks good I love how the dialog
changes like when you actually change
the suit and like in game it changes
it's cool happened
man Harry got the meteorite I
uh I couldn't stop him Connor said we
can't save him so we
have I can't lose him
miles I can't do this
again what you say this game's about
letting
go in your head
it's not your fault Pete she wanted to
save you to save all of
us she never thought about
herself even when she was struggling to
breathe if may I didn't get to have this
conversation if they were here they
would want us to stop thinking about
them love how so much miles is saving
Peter they'd want us to help people
to
fight Harry's still in
there and we're going to fight like hell
to get him back I thought miles needed
Peter so much during the beginning to
middle but really Peter needed
miles that's actually it's a really
strong Trilogy when you think about the
play coach oh yeah call the play coach
he's taking the
lead let split up oh yeah cuz you're
counting uh uh the Miles Morales give
him yeah you find the meteor right I'll
clear that nest
out you got it
Spider-Man the the writing team deserve
I mean everyone deserves so much credit
around but the writing team fantastic
job dialogue is
great offline that's not a good
sign I mean there's a lot of things that
are interfering with the sickness oh
right right right true true true I was
just worried because Venom like has the
uh you know knows that Peter and Miles
just maybe kidnapped
Haley hey everything all good with
Haley not yet but you still owe me a few
more minutes hang
tight Haley no
saver than
kisser
[Applause]
yes there's a good person underneath
what are you doing
here I was I was trying to
save You're
Incredible kiss her I like you so
much I think you like me it's happening
do you want to go out yeah on a
date they should do a double date and
they're
official is that a
yes do not say
no
playing hard to get I like it
Haley well it's a date
then after all this is
over kill off
Haley I'm on the
way
PE I just need that meteorite
okay
e miles not seeing a rock just how it's
turned off so small near and it is just
exponentially grown yeah his his Spider
Sense doesn't go off with
Venom
AR what are you we are
healed finally
free he can give that gift to
everyone but we need you with
us still the ultimate goal to heal the
world Heal the World
together yo bro not
cool we can't stay
[Applause]
here
damn
but what's going on with Yuri and the
cultist we need to call
MJ I know where the meteorite
is last final Story
Mission Central Park Reservoir the water
system pumping goo everywhere adding
more and more people to the hive mind so
this is antivenom suit can he take it
off feels out of Manhattan have control
over it dude great question hello Planet
goo the meteorite is the source of all
the power right creating goo creating
symbiotes but it was useless until Harry
repaired it yeah and that particle
accelerator what damaged it in the first
place cut off a piece at low power right
so what if we rank the power up like way
past 11 might destroy it and free
everyone connected to the hive mind
theoretically but that reservoir's got
to be mobbed with
symbiotes and you know Harry is not
going to let that rock out of his sight
unless he sees something like stranger
things I haven't seen it
Craig just you know for illustrative
purposes Harry's still hay he thinks
he's healing the world but the dream
isn't complete without his best friend
beside him mhm I can lead Harry away
from the meteorite and I can handle all
the Symbiotes while I grab the space
Rock for illustrative purposes all right
right now Eddie Brock is taking photos
of all this right now no more Hive M
definitely well saved we all get your
rose
theoretically
Pete what Conor said about Harry being
too far
gone if you can't save him are you ready
W come to
that you two will be able to destroy the
Rock in
time let's heal the world for real this
time this is what makes me so different
from Peter I would immediately resort to
First horror business kill
her good to know if I'm ever in a
life-threatening situation you do what's
necessary with I was
told thanks
buddy right is somewhere in that thing
so are Harry and his friends
here figured you could use a Sonic
touch the weapon that makes her
Unstoppable doesn't matter how much
training or how Unstoppable you are
she's Unstoppable with
that he's like Venom goons are so funny
I think you're both enough for
everything come on bro we're the spider
team don't anyone forget it they really
are such a good team is gy helping out
at all too though or no nah we don't
need gkey we got the trio
here hey
buddy you going to sit in there and play
with your pet rock all
night it's you and me
Harry like we always
wanted this is so
[Music]
terrifying my best friend our gift will
finally be
yours
here's the thing
though
whoa you're going to have to catch me
first as smart as Venom is sometimes
he's a
little just wants his best friend dude
he's got to know he's being
baited sometimes the heart clouds
judgment logic
[Applause]
MJ
now this clothes
Landing damn it's a great weapon yeah it
really
is oh no this really does feel like
stranger things no you haven't seen it
but there's a lot of stranger things
like into another realm with the high
mind and all this
stuff time to go miles you shoot them
all MJ on the motorcycle you
ready I love this version of MJ
I know Kristen dun is your favorite but
this is
mine this one's pretty hot one isn't
invited to our high school reunion
Harry Harry can't can't sense him SP no
spider no Peter tinkle with
him oh they're back at
Midtown how ironic of all the places how
ironic is where we became best friends
yeah it
is and now it's where we become
brothers see all the music behind
speakers
mhm
whoa holy [__] what a place for a fight
to go down
yeah
ah you want to join
[Music]
us
whoa
Dam I love the The Bleak ickiness of all
of
it it just feels like a poison that's
corrupting just doesn't stop
growing it'll be over
soon
doesn't matter what you do to me I'm
never going to heal the world with you
them are fighting
words the
meteorite you took it from
us what's
happening what's
happening oh my
God this it's like some hellish
Supernatural [__]
man oh my
God I think the goo aliens were mad we
took their stuff yeah well they
started
damn let's get this to the
accelerator did you just destroy your
motorcycle they can't break through that
you hearing
that I love how demonic this
is
uh a full descent into some PG-13
Supernatural
Terror
slingshot pleas try to tear it down on
him he's okay
right that's one way to describe
it
damn Pete's getting knocked out so much
in this
store go miles I've got him
go oh
man dude miles holds his own against
Venom so
well I'll take it
back
[Applause]
we gave you our
chance
Alie
nice oh then sound has got to be driving
him crazy right
now
oh he's
[Music]
lost man where's like the Army you do
think they'd be like called in or
something like what for we got
Spider-Man give me back my
friend we are your
friend oh wow what's happening just hang
on buddy please no leave him alone no oh
here is fighting it
yeah no like it's not Harry's lost to
this
now
wa go
miles man the way the cutting being done
is so well
done
y oh my God
this is so tense choreography
is
whoa double punch this really is a job
for two
Spider-Man Mary J and her amazing
gun just going to say if the city just
has MJ with that gun they don't need
Spider-Man
you got a date to get two
miles right
V
[Music]
woo fight Harry fight I can't I'm done
no you have to oh he's asking for kill
us son of a [__] get find the Bell
you're at the church just bail it off
of that's an iconic
shot
wh
hry
please this is so
emotional I know it's so strenuous
wow what about miles's like soundtrack
thingy yeah I'm done either way we still
have time no we
don't it'll kill
them then it'll kill you no but then
it'll make your dad the Green Goblin and
we don't want
that let's Heal The
World
Together a
[__] I remember earlier we I said to
Peter going into
Harry should see the inside of the
partical accelerator yeah there
[Music]
foreshadowing she really is Unstoppable
with that gun that gun man Mary Jane and
that
gun I just want a solo MJ game with that
we're in
business
just this cacophony of things just
stacking man now
Pete you got no choice
Pete
[Music]
mg
oh to make make the choice
damn very similar to the last game or
the first
game oh
no oh
[Music]
no
I love you
a oh I he his heartbeat
[Applause]
yeah
man what a wild trajectory from getting
hary back to what this all led
to and how there was the hope to save
the world that's that's gnarly it's
like that epic personal Journey this all
[Music]
brought and Norman specifically said to
Spider-Man please save my boy
yep Spider-Man's about to get some blame
for some stuff well it's like the
reverse of Ry Spider-Man 1 where Harry
blamed
uh MJ where's your gun
yeah I'm
sorry I'm
sorry oh he's going to bring him back to
life do
it no way do it please no
way I don't know if it's going to work
but I got to try please please please
oh how cool would that be this is like
M that bio electricity the essential
qualities of miles in this game is so
great so
[Music]
Grand no
way oh my
God
what
what just falling asleep oh okay then
we're going to see Eddie Brock in the
corner taking a photo of
[Music]
them Eddie Brock's been
inspired like I just had the worst
nightmare and see even after defeating
that the anti-venom suit stays on
him well I think you also you're asking
is can he take it off like if he wants
to
those suits are so damaged
[Music]
though I that he always has to make an
entrance in a helicopter that's what
Ultra rich people do is weak we got to
move what have you done what what have
you done to him I'm sorry got I'm coming
with you
wait didn't he say get him out of the
suit and save him
yeah but he's not entirely saved yet no
I know
but know he's in a weakened state but
it's like dude maybe they're Butler can
explain everything to normally there are
traces of brain activity but his chances
of coming back are very slim oh no he's
a vegetable he's in a
coma just keep him alive he's wearing
green he's wearing green for shadowing
become the green
[Music]
Co I love the overarching theme of these
games of characters not knowing how to
grief
yeah
oh they're in his
room well Norman is the poster boy for
that cuz all the events in the first
game were because of
him
why
oh man so tortured I do really
appreciate the the way they decided to
take Norman in this though yeah the love
he has for Emily and his son the G serum
ready what does the G stand
[Music]
for is that like Green Goblins I don't
know for the last few years tragedy has
tried to the city
apart but we somehow kept
going we battled sickness
evil
cataclysm say Trump ISM get political
[Music]
game
numb but we have never lost
[Music]
hope the city needs to heal that's we're
all ready to return to normal
but what is normal normal normal she
move in paying your $4,000 mortgage
what's normal
this over the last half hour I've talked
about how these events have changed me
but what about you oh she is starting a
podcast in this ongoing series I will be
talking with people throughout the city
exploring our new behaviors just saying
that as a
joke and
feelings I hope you'll join me on this
journey that was actually an Easter egg
from the first game they were talking
about moving in with each other they
filled out an application was in the
backpal The New
Normal you almost talked over the
podcast
line almost at the very
end God this is why I yell at you when
the camera's not rolling he
does episode one done
nice I don't know are these good to go
in a minute I want to show you something
let me serve them and I'll take all the
credit
oh that's what they serve at
[Music]
Feast thanks again for the donation
Peter
is he
proposing oh PE
cool now the Emily May
Foundation
[Music]
hope
ah have you talked to Miles
about not
yet it's
quitting you ready
uh
miles I've been meaning to talk to you
uh about some uh I mean I have been
talking to you all the time it's it's
great uh to talk so many good talks I
just haven't been talking to you about
what I should have been talking to you
Pete fill in the blank wait uh let me
start
again I got
this a
Fall Of
It Go be Peter Parker for a
while are you are you sure it's it's a
big
city hand it I'm just going to have to
switch to H school but I got this long
as I can still call you for
advice you don't need
it say a weight of
responsibility letting go maybe not now
but they'll come a time I'm here for you
always except right now you're on your
own you go out in the city see
[Music]
you
oh
Pete Dr Strange shows up but what about
Wraith in the
coldest I want to know about that oh is
there an after credit I assume there's
an after credit I hope not yeah right
yeah it's got to be yeah I mean we can
start talking about it all right well
while we went for a mid credits post
credit what you think of the story
Andrew absolutely epic uh there were so
many different things I could go into I
just love all the themes uh I mean just
letting go grieve not knowing how to let
go grieve uh just oh sorry were you
going to say something no um just yeah
and then obviously seeing so many
characters that we know and love um I
just always love though just the the
atmosphere the tension I love though
also seeing like just how is New York
just able to survive just so many
different and pouts of Destruction and
all that but uh just uh in terms of the
story though it was just like I said it
was epic um just uh seeing Peter and
Miles journey I just love the way they
were able to complement each other in so
many different aspects um the character
Journeys that we got to go through with
both of them uh seeing both of their
perspectives and even too when we got to
see Venom's perspective and Craven's
perspective there was just so many
different things and layers about the
story that I appreciated and the
dialogue and just so many different
other things um that I'm going to go
into but I'll let you get a little in
really quick yeah uh I think that this
was one that wore its themes on its
shoulders so strongly like it's so much
about understanding support obviously
that great line that Aunt May has about
balance being a process not a
destination and you know that's what
Peter's sort of aiming for by the end of
this journey is like hey I just need
like a little bit of a break right now
you know to do this and it's also so
much not just about forgiving others but
learning to forgive yourself as well uh
yeah a lot of them about self
forgiveness and um just self-
understanding along the way and and also
about you know the
darkness within us and how to cope with
it is is about it's a big story about
self-acceptance like there's a lot of a
lot of really positive as as dark of a
story as it becomes and as as like
harrowing of a of a desperate journey
and a toll this takes on everyone I
think that it the the Hope was
constantly piercing that dark Veil
throughout the entire the entire Journey
obviously there's like going to be some
things that we didn't really get via the
gameplay and stuff but but while we're
here just focus on the story itself like
you know like there's such a big theme
about I think self forgiveness is is
such a big part of it it like how many
villains that we see that were about
like reforming you know like got like
Quinton Beck you have Tombstone you have
Mr Lee Mr Mr negative yeah yeah Mr
negative as as one of the characters who
and we didn't get to see the prowler
stuff which is kind of surprising u in
this this specific cut scene take and
and about letting go as well you know
know and learning to trust again like
that was that was such a constant uh
throughout this this whole journey and
yeah I thought I thought there was a lot
of Beauty in something that managed to
be so epically dark it's crazy because
like it's I guess it's bigger than the
first game kind yeah yeah it's bigger
but it's also
more it's so intertwined and so intimate
and personal between like like I love
the choice to make Harry the be the one
Venom because it keeps it personal
rather than competing photographers or
something yeah totally totally this and
I would say too this is my favorite
version of Harry osor that we've ever
gotten and it just when you see him turn
into venom and then like feeling that
betrayal like the way we got and again
this isn't a a comparison even though
it's going to sound like it but with how
it happened in Amazing Spider-Man 2o it
just it felt rushed and the way
everything was set up in the first game
and then actually getting to like really
spend time with these characters here
and the way uh just the way they
interact with each other just you know
you know what's coming you hope it
doesn't happen but then like when it
happens it's like oh no and obviously
you were able to call it out but um good
job by the way um but when it does
happen it's like oh hold on hold on yeah
we'll get back into
it Green
Goblin
here we
[Music]
go God be
Arin talking to AO yeah yeah I think
you're right I think you're right he's
going to ask Oto for help what do you
want wow they're all
partners the
Spider-Man you know who they are the
softness in this voice don't
you
why oh my
God they ruin my son a
dude so
infuriating good
you deserved it we all have to
experience
loss even you
Norman what are you
writing what you did to me the Final
Chapter
make the proper
Trilogy oh another
one oh we going to finally meet the
boyfriend yeah is it Robbie Robertson I
don't
know it's just some random dude can't be
the final scene oh it's Haley oh okay
cool Haley
hi I hope you're
hungry food's almost ready oh I think it
is going to be a double date why don't
you definitely she looks so nervous he
works so hard on it oh she definitely
[Music]
does it's gy sir
tap
oh oh essay some guy in Harlem probably
seen him volunteering in the city
helping out his city council mom and
trying to live up to his hero
dad a yeah that's the scarf Haley gave
him in the first game or in the Miles
Morales excuse
me
yeah it's kind of weird I liked miles
more in this game than I did in his own
game I liked a lot of his own game but I
loved him in his own game but yeah this
game it's is even more
impressive this game too it just fleshed
him out even
more hey that's the scarf that you gave
him yeah I didn't know that thank
you
they could K oh my
god oh I was so
earned Greg prediction who is it you've
been right all game I have no idea man I
really have it's Robbie Robertson I have
no clue who this
be
hey J Jon J
hi miles Haley this is
Albert Albert hi nice to meet you a G oh
and uh this is my daughter Albert
C Cindy
Moon that's
a the [__] what is her name
silk don't know who that is she's um she
was like uh oh God okay I gotta pull the
memory nog in here really quick um she
was also bit by if correct me if I'm
wrong
she was also bit by the same spider that
bit uh Peter
oh cool spider silk yeah that's awesome
I recognized moon right away it took me
a few seconds to process Cindy moon like
I feel like something we didn't show her
oh awesome oh damn so setting it up
Cindy moon in the next G setting up a
spiderverse but I I remember her
backstory being a little bit more on the
tragic side well you can't be a spider
person if I I can't imagine it's the
same backstory because if he's
introducing be but the what I recall
about it is oh my my memory Noggin is so
bad um something
about first off I'm gonna make sure
Cindy moon is silk really quick before I
just look like a total dumbass on camera
I'm sure you're pretty sure I'm right
that I'm sure you're completely right
Cindy Moon
silk
right yes yes yeah yeah oh cool um but
yeah if i' if I'm not mistaken like she
was bit but then she was also like kind
of kept isolated and trained for a long
time before coming out into the real
world but this seems like she's just
kind of a normal
teenager um but yeah that's kind of um
it's kind of crazy that we would get her
in here yeah well obviously she's not
going to be bitten by the same spider
that bit Peter but still um Rio Morales
just can't get away from having children
who are yeah spider kids oh that's so
cool that we're going to get her in here
Co Easter egg cool Easter egg but yeah
know I remember too you were mentioning
uh just about support systems and I mean
support systems are so important just in
just was it the same radioactive spider
she got bit by I don't know I I I
recognize Cindy moon in silk that's what
I remember I might be getting my back
story I'll jumbled honestly um before I
talk about the support system I was
interesting showed Wraith in there and
we didn't get a uh I I wanted to know
more about who that person was she was
talking about the person who was Flame
or in charge of that that organization
flame because I feel like there was
something important there it's probably
missing from it but you know we got the
main story yeah yeah I'm glad we at
least got to see uh WTH in there like
I'm I'll you're you're playing the game
right now I'll play the game in a couple
months well yeah well well I mean
obviously you know you were talking
about not handling griefing very well
and obviously Yuri didn't handle the
grief very well of just what had
happened to all her fellow officers so I
mean yeah you just see what happens uh
yeah I mean she I felt well they have
that line about like I think the line
about process is so
important because so much about grief is
about processing and I think when you
look at where the path that Yuri went
well Yuri's not a bad guy though you
know it's like wraith and and um wraith
and Spider-Man have their differences
Yuri's not a bad guy and and then you
have Norman who's not processing either
and is like they have to to still blame
somewhere you know same thing with Otto
they're they're the representations of
characters who don't know who who like
place blame when they don't need to
especially Norman like dude what the
hell's wrong with you man yeah he was
like son he was gonna die he was gonna
die or be all consumed and live as this
forever there was literally no other
choice you have your Dr Conor is right
there who works for you to to absolutely
confirm that there was literally no
other way and and he's here to blamed
but but I like the direction of what
they're setting up of you can have um
you like he he knows that auto knows the
identity at least the identity of one of
them because he said you know the
Spider-Man but he would only know the
identity of one of them right right yeah
cuz uh when Otto fought at Peter at the
end of the first game miles had just
only been bitten so but I think uh
Norman's whole thing is it's process of
elimination if I figure out who one is
I'm going to figure out who that the
second one is um but you also mentioned
earlier too just about uh support uh
systems and how important it is and I
just love how this game just really
highlighted it
because I really love just how like
Miles when he it it felt like him and
Peter were already growing apart once
Harry got back into the picture so you
know even though we didn't really get to
see I'm not going to go into spoilers of
what happens even though I kind of
already finished the prowler missions if
you will but basically um you know he's
there to fill that void for uh Miles
when they are getting divided if you
will and I just love that in a moment
that he needs Peter so much and it kind
of flips itself on its head that Peter
needs miles so much and that just miles
is able to just grow so much when you
know he needs to and I love that line
too it's like I'm not going to forgive
you but I'm not going to hold this
hatred towards you and like that's what
his dad would want you know and yes I
mean his dad always preached him about
you know a hero is not a someone who
would give up but also his dad like
didn't believe in hate because his dad
never had hatred towards his brother for
what he did in terms of being the
prowler but he was just disappointed in
the choices that he made and he wouldn't
want the same thing for miles and miles
understood that and I just like it it
kind of really came full circle and I
just really appreciated that Arc so much
like my again I love the storyline
characterization we got for Harry and
and Peter was just so well fleshed out
and their arcs were just
chef's kiss what did you think about
Craven I we definitely could have gotten
way more of him um I mean I I I'm
assuming again I haven't played the game
I'm assuming there's a lot that they
didn't show us in and Bandon didn't show
us because um there was I I really feel
like there was a lot missing um just in
terms of characterization because all I
got from him was he wanted the hunt and
um
that was it yeah um it's a very
two-dimensional charact at least in just
the cut scenes and a little bit of
gameplay they showed us I it felt very
twood dimensional I have to just reserve
my my thought again I I don't know
what's missing I have to reserve my
thoughts for I have to play the game now
to see what was missing because again
playing the game there were definitely
some things missing from uh from this uh
thing that we're reacting to from this
video so to happen yeah no and I get
that and there's only so much you can
fit in which I appreciate all the hard
work that he did putting into this thank
you so much um Bandon uh but yeah just
what we did get from Bandon um yeah I'm
in agree I I still love the the look of
him and how intimidating he was and I
truly did feel other than when Venom was
fighting him of course that no one stood
an actual shot against him so from that
perspective I really appreciated from
characterization and arcs and all that
stuff like it just really felt two
dimensional um but again I'm going to
reserve my thoughts just in case there
was a whatever was missing um so I want
to play the game first just to but from
what we saw in here two very
two-dimensional yeah little two-
dimensional um but overall I still I
enjoy I like I think he has presence
when he's there but I did kind of crave
a little new more Nuance from him
especially cuz he was built up one of
the main villains of of this you know
what I mean yeah totally like he's the
big Catalyst to everything that that
ends up up happening you know um and
then there's like so much time spent
with all like the hunters and everything
that I do think like I like Mary Jane a
lot in this especially when she's got
her I like her a lot in this but it does
kind of under like just from a narrative
standpoint I'm sure in the game like
fighting the hunters can be a pain in
the ass but from a narrative standpoint
it is like if she's just like sneaking
around whooping their asses and stuff
all the time like why is it so hard for
how how difficult going to be for the
Spider-Man to really handle them when
she can just like sneak up on them and
yeah when I told you the element of
surprise it's perable attack and also
too they just undervalue this Spiderman
never has the element of surprise yeah
they they just undervalue this redheaded
woman with a taser gun they stood no
chance I'm telling you insomnia get on
that Mary Jane Watson game with her
taser she's the real hero I mean miles
could just literally retire and just
have Mary Jane going around with a taser
gun New York would be safe forever
there is a scenario there I loved miles
here um I think my favorite character
he's an ultimate support system but I I
love how like okay the the the last one
you know is very much established that
Peter is the mentor role and then he's
able to make his own become into his own
and here even upon an introduction he's
still secondary to Peter and then he
really does feel like he's become his
equal in this game and I think that's
why I was gravitated towards him so much
here because uh there's a while a lot of
the story keeps them separate I think
that was that was a great call and I
really believed in miles and every step
of the way like while Peter was able to
like they would say they would they
would go around saving each other but I
really think miles does become his
ultimate equal here that to the point
where when Peter does decide like hey I
want to be Peter Parker I want to be
Peter Parker for a while while and miles
is the one to be like I got this I
really I feel that I feel that Miles
actually does have it and and not in a
like the the story is forcing me to feel
that it it it seems so natural of how we
actually landed there yeah no just from
everything he's achieved throughout the
game and not just from a physical
perspective just mentally too just from
all the lines we just talked about too
just from his actions and just like what
you said like he's equally like he is
Spider-Man like I mean and he's earned
that again it's an or it's a very
organic thing that he's earned the place
of uh New York's protector he's not
Harlem Spider-Man he's New York
Spider-Man now and yeah there were
situations where we're like how could
Peter do some of these things on his own
and it's going to be interesting too
like seeing I'm sure whenever Spider-Man
3 does or they could probably do another
side game or something like that but
sure um I mean we're going to have to
see Peter Parker again obviously uh but
yeah no I mean he he's definitely earned
it after everything and again I just
love all the situations that came apart
where it's like no he really did grow on
his own like and it's again the game
didn't force miles to to do that he just
he organically became his own man
through the wisdom of his father his
mother and the support system he has all
around him he became his own man and I I
just appreciate that so much really came
full circle as a character just love his
storyline so much and while the big the
huge huge moments of of a lot of the big
emo moments went to Peter um miles's
journey of learning to like again I love
the Nuance of he's not it's not a
journey of him forgi like there's
there's the feeling of forgiveness and
then there's the action of forgiveness
yeah and it's like he goes through with
the action of forgiveness but he doesn't
go through with the um you know he can't
go through with the emotion like I I
love the Nuance of that yeah no he I
mean he understands why Martin Lee did
what he did but he's still not going to
forgive him but again at the same time
he's still not going to hate him yeah um
because and and I think that's what
makes him Spider-Man is especially with
Peter who is consumed by Darkness
consumed by this thing it it is the
values of Spider-Man and the ability to
motivate and instill that in him in a
time where it seems completely hopeless
yeah that allows Peter to come out of
that and rip the Symbiote off that he is
he is the driving factor and it's stuff
like that that makes a Spider-Man not
like yeah we like the powers and all
that yeah uh but uh it's really the the
value system for sure and with all the
grief and hatred that Miles felt before
like you know he came to that
realization like I can't live with all
this hate it would have also been
interesting to see obviously I'm glad
with the way everything like unfolded
but it would have been interesting to
see like the Symbiote get attached to
him as well um but still like we didn't
need that I'm just saying got a part
three yeah one day one day the it'll
attach to miles but I'm just saying like
that would have been interesting too
even though again we did not need that
so I Concur and uh Venom was really cool
I love how Tony to just killed it The
Voice work was great on him um I love
the choice to make venom a a
representation that Praise on one's
grief as venom does as the Symbiote does
yeah but to have it be the embod because
we've seen like so many different
versions of Venom you primarily the
Eddie Brock version is the one that
we're used to seeing that to see it
inhabit that of Osborne yes it allowed a
sympathetic Gateway into seeing Venom of
knowing that like there's a soul trapped
in there that you really care about
preserving and that you want to protect
like it makes it more conflicting when
you're fighting vom you know what I mean
sure for sure and I love not just
straight up evil yeah no and they set it
up too earlier in the game where like
when it's you know and Harry at the
beginning like Harry's happy um he's not
grieving as I mean he's still grieving
for his mother obviously but he's happy
to be with his friends he's happy to be
out of the tank he's healthy he's happy
so therefore it's not you know
possessing him in an evil maniacal way
and then once uh you know it switches
over to uh Peter and then he's uh what
he's been stabbed so now he's in
survival like dreaded uh mode now it
starts conflicting him in an evil uh way
uh and then you know then it reject then
he rejects it and then it switches over
to Harry who now feels betrayed
it just prays upon your you know your
your thoughts and all that and the way
you're going about it so I just thought
it was just so interesting how it had a
mind of its own I just love the way they
went about that and just how they set it
up and again Insomniac they just deserve
so much credit the way how they laid so
many different seeds in the first game
and in Miles moral and then just just
sprinkle it and let it grow and Blossom
uh in this game I mean there was just so
many things they set up in the first
game in Miles Morales and just paid it
off in such a big way in this game I
mean what they do with their villains I
think is great because they always
manage to give you a a sense of hope
that they could change other than Craven
um but like even with Norman setting him
up like if you just transferred Norman
from the first game to to Green Goblin
in the next I could sort I could see
that um but here this allows you the
opportunity to to Really humanize Norman
so much to the point where it's rued in
pain that you're like no no I I could
see there's a good guy in you still
there's still a good like they they
layered him so much more here that you
could see there's a good person in there
and you you're hoping that you you could
kind of like magnify that light him to
stop and you're like but we know you got
to become Green Goblin like we know
that's the path you're destined for and
that that is the thing about grief you
know
like to feel the pain of it can be too
much that to it can be easier to feel
the blame and anger to hide away from
the pain yeah and that is where he's and
I like that it's rooted in that yeah you
know and you could see too in regards to
Norman like what he went through with
Emily uh already lost his wife where he
lost his wife and he's just how much
love he has for Harry uh he's just it's
going through that again with Harry it's
just not an option for him and I just
again I love the charact this is and he
can't take accountability for like we
doe to piig part of this is your fault
you're the one who gave him the S yeah
yeah that too but I mean it was
interesting choice they made at the end
of the first game uh in regards to like
Norman was willing to put the entire
city at risk to save Harry whereas Peter
was willing to sacrifice M to save the
whole city so that's the difference
between the two of them I think it's
what they've been doing as a buildup to
to Spider-Man's greatest enemy I mean
some people say it's venom but to me
it's Green Goblin it's green I mean
Venom is right there but it's it's
always been Green Goblin for me Green
Goblin's is Joker to to me yeah yeah but
Venom is damn right here there but I
think I think it's cooler to Save Green
Goblin for your third one oh for sure
and I think I think these games have
been a great build to that oh yeah you
got to you got to have green there's too
much set up to not have green Goin there
but um I mean so far uh this is my
favorite characterization of Norman and
Harry and I'm just like I just love how
personal it gets and how close uh uh
people is with them as well and just
like it it just feels all the more
personal when he's fighting him as Venom
and again the setup that we got for him
as Green Goblin the next game I'm just
I'm so EXC I love this franchise so much
the it don't it doesn't feel like a
video game it's just it feels so
cinematic uh so it's it's going to be
interesting to see again hard to compare
because this is five and a half however
long hours in terms of cutscenes um it's
hard to compare in terms of you know to
film you know it's not because they only
get what two two and a half hours hour
or so but it's going to be damn hard to
compete with this in terms of obviously
you got the animated films into the
spiderverse across the spiderverse are
freaking amazing films and then you got
these incredible games in terms of Miles
Morales because you know they're going
to obviously bring miles into the fold
in regards to the MCU or the Sony
whatever it's going to be hard to
compete that's all I'm saying I'm I'm
curious to see how they do it I'm
excited for because Miles Morales is one
of my favorite uh comic book characters
in general so I'm very curious how they
are going to do it all I'll say is Good
Luck Good Luck cuz uh this is two very
tough uh versions that are pretty damn
good so hey man we got a journey yeah we
got a journey yeah but hey look two
different versions that are fantastic
why can't we add a third one right I
mean we got like a billion versions of
Spider-Man it's true true all righty
guys well uh from just a narrative
standpoint other than like the little
bit of letdown from from cven yeah um I
will definitely let you know when I play
the game in full like if there was stuff
missing or not but I I agree that was a
little bit of that was that my only
nitpick of a let down was that from just
a story experience on this first go
around um I'm going to give the story
itself like a nine out of 10 n n maybe a
9.5 I was going to go 9.4 you beat me
all right
yeah okay I'll go 9.37
okay uh yeah no I loved it this was this
was a this was a fun watch and would you
say it's your favorite of the three so
far just from fresh out of it or is you
got to let some time I think from a
story experience the sensibilities of it
speak to me the most yeah I would I
would I would definitely say definitely
better than the m not the biggest fan of
the Miles Morales game why not Simon
creger was the best
villain not generic in anyway I like the
game I did I really enjoyed it and it
made me love miles uh but I'm not the I
definitely felt like um I don't want to
say like a step down but it was it was
not as great as the first Spider-Man
game well it was supposed to be like hey
just we got something special for you
just in between that next big game that
we're sitting up for you so but uh no I
I I I I thought this one was pretty
great um I really love the experience of
it um a lot and in all seriousness like
yeah I know some people get a little bum
when they're like why are you just doing
it this way but like timely coverage if
we waited months people wouldn't have
care guys we could have done it like
this or we could have just done what we
did with Miles morouse and just reviewed
it for you so I mean no one watches guys
guys you got to give Greg all the credit
like he does a lot of work with this so
seriously thank you so much you know
admittedly assembling each one of these
only takes about three to three and a
half hours to put one of these together
Which is less time time than the other
videos I normally put together
significantly less so yeah admittedly
like this is one of the lazy Renditions
of of our videos [__] still it's still a
lot of work so I have to you have to
factor in like I am doing this in
between all the other stuff as well and
and like there is a kind of like a lot
of stuff that we're just covering right
now if we could have played it we would
have just if I had the time right now
but it's not it's not doable guys but
once I read it was like once I read it
was like oh if you just like get through
it it could be like 30 to 40 hours I was
like so in my world that's like 50 to 60
hours I know you and then you got to
Factor he's got to get me on the time
same time frame as that and then he's
got to edit all that like that's just
it's just not doable as much as we would
love to do that for we just haven't
figured out some for and we're not a
gaming channel so you know one day one
day we'll uh one day I'll figure it out
this was this was the first
step um but thank you guys so much for
being here and thank you for all who
have been on the journey with us thanks
Andrew for joining me my pleas everybody
thank you for having me and we will
catch you all soon peace out reject
Nation I've had this knife here for days
for no
[Music]
reason